julie bonjour sa alu casimir tu as l'air
en pleine forme
ça va très bien j'ai mal au dos et c'est
pour ça que tu te promènes avec tombola
du lobby bull car tu as envie de réhab
laurence moi je me suis aperçu un jour
ma boutique que j'avais précise de tout
l'outré mer c'est pas de ma faute parce
que j'aimerais ça dira le ce matin il
n'avait pas le ranger avec je suis
revenue je ne savais plus quoi sert
aussi lui dire déjà tu ne peux pas le
gloubiboulga à bout mais alors pourquoi
tu as apporté ton bol et bien j'ai là
une nouvelle recette de cuisine quand je
voudrais que tu me prépares à pont-d'ain
écoute donne moi ta recette pour deux
voix si j'ai tous les produits
c'est ma tante adélaïde qui me l'a
donnée sparaco c'est délicieux et du
gala bourg à bout rien que le nom ça me
donne faim mettre un peu de miel dans le
fond d'un bol bien écraser dedans de
truffes en chocolat est allé le mélange
les parois du bol avec les doigts avec
les doigts puis je vais avoir les mains
toutefois sur l'île oui mais il faut
suivre exactement la recette sinon elle
sera ratée bon bah tu sais c'est bien
parce que c'est toi à temps il faut que
je vois d'abord si j'ai tous les
produits parce qu'une fois que j'aurai
plongée mais ma dans le miel et chocolat
je ne pourrai plus toucher à rien alors
il faut du miel des truffes au chocolat
de la crème chantilly un oeuf dur away
mais y aura quelques lardons deux
champignons des petits pois et voilà
c'est exactement ce que fait marquant sa
des live vous étiez pas tu sais
cette recette de gala pour abonde n'a
pas l'air plus appétissante que celle de
globules bowling je suis sûr que cette
délicieuse voilà bonjour j'ai dit
bonjour casimir sa soirée soit aaa
bonjour baby rich mckay ce qui se
passait c'est kobe c'est casimir qui m'a
demandé de préparer une nouvelle recette
de sa tante adélaïde un cas la cour à
pau cela se fait avec les doigts
oui tu vois c'est plutôt pas seul et tu
en as pour longtemps oh oui c'est
compliqué c'est vraiment pas de chance
moi j'ai juste le temps d'apporter ma
commande de ballons avant le départ du
bateau
ah bon mais pourquoi tu n'écris pas mes
mains regarde pas ce qui est arrivé
bah je me suis foulé la main en essayant
de décoincer match mais on ne sait pas
trop non c'est terminé maintenant mais
très ennuyeux parce que je comptais sur
toi pour écrire ma place ma lettre de
commande bons mais moi j'ai pas obéi
toute excuse moi casimir mais il faut
que ce soit écrit sa lettre tout de
suite
moi j'ai une idée tu continues à
préparer mon gala bourbon est moi
j'écris à lettre de françois qu'est ce
que tu crois que tu vas y arriver la
sueur
on peut toujours essayer qui ne risque
rien n'a rien casimir tu es certain d'y
arriver est évidemment alors viens avec
loire ni avec moi nous verrons tu est
certaine je sais écrire à montlaur
casimir ya tout ce qu'il faut là droit
yann écritoire tu as du papier par
patrick raffin une plume tu t'installes
ou bien voilà alors allons-y tu es prêt
à temps je me ferais pas ça va et vient
elle aussi voyez je suis prêt monsieur
[Musique]
je vous recommande 300 ballons français
et doucement je vous recommande 303
anneaux et du cygne françois sauvadet
c'est pour ça y est oui c'est fini ccoo
alors c'est tout je parlais en europe si
tu veux rien
enfin casimir mais c'est une catastrophe
je peux pas envoyer sa voix est pourquoi
nous enfin quel finir c'est plein de
fautes d'orthographe
tu crois ah bah oui monsieur monsieur
s'écrit mondiaux-2009 a pas de u vous
yes commande un seul mouvement coûte il
ya une faute d'orthographe par mokake du
mur c'est pas possible enfin bon il ne
s'est pas très important là comment tu
dit li l'orthographe mais au contraire
c'est très important
et si chacun écrivait comme ça ne porte
comment ce serait très difficile de
l'ironique aux poudres est rien bon on
écoute on va lui demander à jeudi pour
voir si elle comprend aussi de voyager
parce que si tu veux bien dire puisque
c'est que ce charabia tu vois des émirs
qu'est ce que je vois je vois rien du
tout lis chaque mort ne cieux je vous
recommande 300 wallon françois à tu vois
à la compris bon c'était pas facile que
gémir c'est tout simplement
incompréhensible c'est quoi c'est
incompréhensible
mul sciex jure on coule casimir le
marchand ne de ballots à croire une
farce et moi j'aurais jamais ma commande
moi je ne savais pas trouvé utile que
c'est compréhensible ah ah oui non tu
veux quoi allô allô bonjour madame je
voudrais le marchand de ballons en
france
oui en france de la part de françois
delisle aux enfants bonjour monsieur 1
j'ai une commande à vous passer de la
part de françois
voilà je vous lis sa lettre monsieur je
vous commande 300 wallon françois vous
avez compris
il a compris bien merci
il les aura demain parfait très bien
merci au revoir
[Musique]
voyez il a compris quant à moi j'ai
trouvé enfin le métier qu'il me faut ah
oui je vais écrit ban public car oui et
tu feras bien de beaucoup travailler
pourquoi pour payer la communication
entre la france et l'île aux enfants
bras